Hey it's me Destin and welcome
back to smarter every day!
I have a problem, there is a specific water phenomenon
that I see happening all around me
but I have no idea how it works
I've been trying to figure it out for
years, in fact i put a video on this
channel in 2011, asking people to help me
figure it out!
there's something interesting happening
here I don't understand it it looks like
water droplets are standing on water
droplets. It looks like water is
hydrophobic it looks like when a bead of
water skates across the hot griddle it
creates a layer of water vapor underneath it
only that's not what it is
If you have any information please let me know
I'd appreciate it
you've seen this right? If you watch the
world with a critical eye like I do
you'll see this everywhere for example
if you've ever allowed yourself to watch
a drip coffeemaker when the conditions
are just right you'll notice that coffee
beads up on top of coffee
what does it do that sometimes when you
turn the shower head on the water will
blast to the other side of the tub
instead of making the bottom of the tub
wet these pearls of water will dance on
top of the water that's already in the
bottom of the tub. Don't let this weird you
out it's just water and food coloring
but the interesting thing is if you get
the stream in just the right location
and interacts with a porcelain and the
water that's in the toilet and just the
right fashion you'll get these little drops
that bead up. I don't understand what the
conditions required to make it happen
are, but I get really excited about it and I
want to understand.
Seriously one time we landed an Apache helicopter on the pad
at work, and the environmental control system
was leaking condensate down onto the
asphalt, and the beads were happening there
that was the moment I realized i have to
know why this is happening. In order to
figure it out we're going to Science Garage
to see my friend Don Pettit who
has out-of-this-world experience in the
area of surface chemistry
let's go get Smarter Every Day.
its water dancing on water, but we're gonna do it
here on earth, and then in space, that OK?
Yeah, and we're going to water down this one!
[laughs] that's bad.
if you know who Don Pettit is you understand why I came to him
it's rare to find a person that not only
understands how to capture beautiful photos
but also understands the
fundamental science behind each image
seriously who else do you know that
collects books on surface chemistry and
wedding phenomena you own these
references?
Yeah.
Really?
Well I mean when you're into this kind of
stuff you need it, right?
Anyways scientists all over the world
have created elaborate setups in their
labs to try to observe these dancing
drops and they've got some really great
data but I knew if I got the right type
of camera in Don's hands
and just turned him loose
we would not only get the data but
we would do it beautifully
it's a Phantom v2511 which is a very very
fast camera and its really loud but
we're gonna turn on the science here
and give it a go
after only about an hour of
working through the lenses and lighting
with Don, he quickly came up with a setup
to observe a beautiful single drop of
water landing on, bouncing, and then
coalescing into a larger pool of water
alright so we have a drop balancing on a
still surface of water and you'll notice
that it isn't coalescing.
Coalescence is when you have two pieces of water that
touch and then merge to become one piece.
Now you notice there's this delay time
where the drop is sitting there before
coalescence that's called the 'Residence Time'
tand scientists have a pretty good
understanding of what's going on here.
As a drop touches the surface scientists
believe there's air trapped in-between
as the drop rests that air starts to
seep out of that gap and then
coalescence occurs.
The National Institute of Health did this really cool
study where they verified the air gap theory
by reducing the air pressure
around coalescing water drops and as
you'd expect the lower the air pressure
to lower the residence time which is
really cool
anyway you can plainly see on the video
that Don captured that as the drop comes
to a rest it starts to slowly bob up and
down and then it's like a little water bridge
is built in that air gap and then
coalescence occurs so this is my
question in the phenomenon I'm seeing
I'm seeing a steady state bouncing of a
drop which means there's impacts
happening over and over
why is that not punching through that
air gap and causing coalescence to
happen easier? In order to understand this
we actually have to look at that impact
which means this is about to get awesome
this is a device that's been shipped to me
from another youtube channel
Ben at NightHawkInLight and he has
drops of water that he puts on water
which is sitting in a speaker so we're
about to basically recreate the setup
that Ben did. So full disclosure you've
done this in space right?
I have!
But we're going to use this high-speed
camera to understand the phenomenon here
on earth and then you're going to teach
me about what you discovered in space
right?
Yeah we're gonna, we're gonna start
on earth and end up in space
[phone ringing]
Hello?
Hey Ben it's Destin, how are you
Yeah and this is Don
we're in science garage here having fun
Awesome, Don it's cool to hear from you
what frequency and amplitude
worked out best for you?
worked out best for you.
[Beep]
if we were to turn that speaker off right now they
would go away right?
Well let's see.
Okay
See? They're there but they coalesce very quickly
So, okay keep doing that don't
change anything we'll change one variable
OK.
That's me turning on the vibration of
the speaker. So what I think is
happening is; the water is trying to
settle and go down and press against the surface
Uh-huh that's right.
But because it's
being pushed back up due to that
vibration it, it adds energy back into
the system and then pushes it away
And I'm saying that that process keeps the
small air gap between the drop, it helps maintain that
You can sit here and postulate things
till you're blue in the face,
until you make an observation to see
what that fundamental physics is, then
you can back out what's going on and
high-speed of what's going on with that
drop it would do a lot to help answer these questions
this is quickly becoming
one of the most awesome setups I've ever
been a part of, would y'agree?
Yeah this is just totally awesome.
But you've been to space!
Allright, here we are
the moment of truth after years of waiting
we finally have everything we
need in order to make
an actual observation. Here we go.
and there it is
did you see it? When i first saw this
footage it stood out to me like a sore
thumb instead of crashing into the drop
like I anticipated it's almost like
those peaks and valleys make some type
of moving catcher's mitt that gently
catches the drop and lets it down gently
without breaking that air layer
now i want to zoom in and see if we can
see that wave catch the drop
there it is it's pretty clear what's
going on here think about it this way if
somebody threw you a water balloon would
you rush your hand up and try to meet it
really quickly and risk bursting that
surface tension? No, you would try to
match the velocity of the balloon with
your hands so you could decrease the
collisional kinetic energy in fact
there's an equation for how to calculate
collisional kinetic energy and that's
what factors into whether or not the
drop survives if the velocity of the
liquid and the small drop are about the
same then that factor goes to 0 and the
collisional kinetic energy quickly
decreases to zero now that we understand
this we can infer that timing is a huge
factor here and there's probably a bunch
of drops that just don't survive because
they hit the wave wrong
in fact that's exactly what we see in
the high-speed. One more thing to think
about is the fact that gravity is
constantly pulling the drops back down
to that vibrating surface which means it
always has to find the soft spot to land
the larger the drop, the greater the
gravitational force pushing down on it.
But what if you did this somewhere where
there was no weight on the drop?
Oh, then it bounces off
I've got the video.
Can we see it?
Yeah!
I discovered this phenomenon for myself
occurring naturally in the woods of
alabama in 2011, the same year that
Don Pettit launched to the international
space station where he accidentally
recreated the phenomenon in a really
remarkable way. He performed a very
similar water speaker experiment, except
in weightlessness the water forms a
sphere. Just to make it interesting Don
put an air bubble on the inside of that
water sphere and then he played tones
through the speaker just to see what
would happen
[Don]... and the air bubble is attached
to the speaker cone, and so is
the water and i'm at 60 Hertz i'm going
to start increasing the amplitude, here we go
Wow. So we're getting a series of
standing nodes on the interface of the
air bubble with the water. I'm going to
put a square wave in
OK... triangle wave
So Don played with different frequencies, amplitudes,
he played different types of music like rock
and roll, and then he played the cello
Don said whenever he played cello music specifically,
little drops would break off
on the inside of the sphere
and start bouncing around on the inside.
A Cello!?
There's something about the Cello!
[Music: Bach's Cello Suite No. 1 - Prelude]
This video sets my brain. on. fire.
We've learned two main mechanisms for
coalescence we have the weight of the
drop that squishes that air boundary and
makes it go
we have no weight, so we're left with
collisional kinetic energy every
collision that results in the
coalescence, everything is right there
and you can just directly see what's happening
the sidewall that's vibrating? It makes
the small drops go faster than the big
drops, because there's lower mass but
it's the same amount of excitation energy
i really liked this video
it's beautiful on multiple levels and I
I want you to think it's beautiful too
[Music: Bach Cello Suite 1]
this has been a huge science goal for me
for a really long time, so I want to say thankyou
to the google making in science team
for making this video possible thank you
so much if you would seem really cool
videos check out the hashtag #sciencegoals
there's all kinds of videos being
uploaded all the time for example check
out Ben at NightHawkInLight, obviously he
helped me make this video it was his
speaker setup that helped us do the
stable bouncing droplets in this video
or check out Diana AKA PhysicsGirl who
teaches you how to make anti-bubbles in
your own home using household items
or you can go check out this cool video
by Derek at Veritasium who explains that the
bouncing drop mechanism can be used to
model quantum theory. He uses bouncing
drops of silicone oil to reproduce the
double-slit experiment check out any of
these other videos under the hashtag #sciencegoals
to go see really awesome science content
A huge thank you to Don Pettit
for sharing his knowledge of
surface chemistry and his orbital footage
in a really humble way that was awesome
thank you Don! Last thing, the v2511
the Phantom that we used in this video
that's now thing on smarta every day
which has also been a science goal for a
really long time so if you're interested
in subscribing you've ever thought about
it now is a really good time to do that
because the slow mo is about to get slower
it's about the higher resolution and
it's about to get more fun. Feel free to
click my face if you'd like to subscribe if not that's it.
I'm Destin, you're getting smarter every day.
Have a good one.